[Música]
y
el 20 de junio es decir el lunes de esta
semana es conmemorado fue conmemorado el
día internacional de los refugiados una
fecha que como muchas otras fechas
conmemorativas sirve para hacer balance
de la situación de las personas que se
ven forzadas a huir de sus hogares si
comparamos cifras según números que
entrega acnur el número de personas
desplazadas por las guerras la violencia
la persecución y también las violaciones
a los derechos humanos ascendía a 89,3
millones de personas según números
reportados a finales del año 2021 si
comparamos las cifras una década atrás
representa un incremento del 8% pero el
24 de febrero comenzó la invasión de
rusia a ucrania y el panorama cambió por
completo esto desencadenó una crisis de
desplazamiento forzado que ya es
considerada como la más grande y también
la más rápida desde la segunda guerra
mundial lo que ha elevado las cifras por
encima de los 100 millones de personas
desplazadas áfrica américa latina'
ucrania por supuesto por el conflicto
que está viviendo
ganis tan irak y siria siguen siendo los
puntos críticos de acuerdo con el banco
mundial son un total de 23 los países
que están presentando conflictos de
larga data o que comenzaron a presentar
diferentes conflictos
que han surgido en los últimos meses en
conjunto todos estos 23 países son suman
una población de 850 millones de
personas que se están enfrentando a
conflictos de intensidad media y alta
según indica este organismo
internacional sin embargo hay una luz de
esperanza y en el 2021 el número de
personas refugiadas y desplazadas que
han retornado a sus hogares llega a
niveles previos al inicio de la
emergencia provocada por la pandemia del
cobi 19 la repatriación voluntaria
también llegó entonces al 71% que son
según este informe el informe es una
cifra positiva pero sigue siendo una
cifra muy modesta un ejemplo positivo
del regreso de miles de personas a sus
hogares gracias a la coordinación con
autoridades y también con organismos
internacionales es costa de márfil en
áfrica en donde hay un significativo
número de personas que han regresado y
han abandonado a los países en donde
estaban como refugiados para regresar a
este país africano después de esa crisis
política que desató una ola de violencia
sin precedentes en la historia de esa
nación del occidente africano
son entonces las medidas instauradas
hasta ahora inadecuadas para luchar
contra el desplazamiento forzado que
tanto compromiso hay de los gobiernos y
también de los organismos para revertir
esta situación se está normalizando por
decirlo de alguna manera el
desplazamiento y las crisis humanitarias
como esta es algo crónico que ya es
parte de la sociedad de la humanidad ver
a la gente dejar sus hogares y huir para
buscar mejores condiciones de vida qué
estrategia funcionó por ejemplo en el
caso de costa de marfil en donde los
números como les digo evidencian una
mejoría la situación de los refugiados y
de los desplazados en el mundo es
nuestro tema de análisis y de debate
aquí en france24 y para analizar este
tema saludamos a civil a brod shinsky
ella es vocera regional para acnur en
las américas ella se encuentra en la
ciudad de méxico en la capital mexicana
y en la ciudad de madrid en españa se
conecta desde allí virginia álvarez es
responsable de política interior e
investigadora sobre migraciones en
amnistía internacional españa les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación dejen sus preguntas
y sus comentarios a través de nuestras
redes sociales estamos en twitter en
instagram y en facebook en donde nos
encuentran como france24 bajo ese arroba
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal en
youtube también pueden encontrar nuestra
señal en streaming la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios le doy la palabra
entonces a civil ahí también le doy la
bienvenida al programa gracias por
acompañarnos hoy aquí en el debate de
france 24 y la primera pregunta es
nuestro punto de partida quiero conocer
impresiones generales y vila de la
situación de los refugiados en el mundo
brevemente y simplemente para conocer su
opinión general sobre la situación y
sobre este informe que fue presentado
por acnur en días pasados
muchísimas gracias
pues resumirse súper bien los números
de cierta forma hablan por sí solos
se ha incrementado el número de personas
desplazadas forzosamente cada año
durante la última década
esto se debe a
muchas razones pero pero la digamos una
de las factores principales es que a
medida que
digamos no se resuelvan los conflictos o
las crisis que llevan a las personas a
desplazarse
se abren nuevos conflictos empiezan
nuevas crisis entonces este aumento
digamos de personas se va se ve
año tras año y es una digamos es un reto
enorme gigantesco para la comunidad
internacional y para los países de
acogida de poder recibir a estas
personas darles la protección
internacional que necesitan y luego en
el momento en que sé que es posible
ayudarlos ya sea a retornar a sus países
de origen cuando la situación en el
terreno lo pérdida o integrarse en los
países de asilo no y la otra opción es
el reasentamiento
claro y virginia también le dé la
bienvenida al programa y en la ciudad de
madrid la capital española sus
impresiones generales sobre la situación
mundial estas cifras que han revelado
estos informes que nos tienen que poner
en alerta sobre la situación que estamos
viviendo
efectivamente como bien indicaba
la cifra desgraciadamente de personas
que huyen de violaciones de derechos
humanos y que huyen de conflictos que
vienen también de la crisis climática
que está provocando también muchos
desplazamientos forzados no para de
crecer
y también no paran de crecer las
desigualdades y la
responsabilidad con la que la
solidaridad mejor dicho con la que
responden los diversos países es muy
diferente también porque mucho de este
sufrimiento y muchos de que surge que
tienen estas personas que podría haber
paliado también con una mayor
solidaridad internacional hablando desde
aquí desde europa
y tenemos un conflicto muy cerca como
bien menciona a guste que es ucrania y
el ejemplo claro de cuando las cosas se
quieren hacer mejor se pueden hacer se
puede responder rápidamente que choca
ampliamente con la respuesta que europa
está dando a personas que huyen de
violaciones de derechos humanos en otras
partes del mundo
sí bueno pues ahí tenemos las
impresiones generales de nuestras dos
invitadas en paso a preguntarle ahora a
virginia para hacer la ronda a la
inversa ya le doy la palabra civil a
sobre
este incremento en las cifras constante
que es lo que está fallando en las
estrategias a nivel global para que
estas cifras no estén dando marcha atrás
que cada vez haya más personas que
tienen que abandonar sus hogares
entiendo el tema de los conflictos el
tema de ucrania es el más claro gente
que se ve obligada a salir del país pero
por ejemplo venezuela es un país que no
está en una guerra civil no está siendo
invadido por una fuerza extranjera es un
caso muy particular
que es lo que está fallando entonces en
las estrategias
bueno las personas se ven obligadas a
salir por muchas razones
en ocasiones es verdad que se ven
empujadas a salir por conflictos armados
pero también en otros casos tienen que
salir de sus países de origen por
persecución individual o por falta de
libertades o como digo también muchas
veces el motivo de salir
está motivado también por razones
económicas
en muchas circunstancias
a lo que me refería antes la falta de
libertades por un lado los conflictos
armados por otro la falta de
oportunidades la crisis climática que
también está obligando a muchas personas
que no tienen recursos en la zona donde
donde viven está obligando a salir de
sus países las migraciones es algo que
ha existido siempre los movimientos
humanos han existido siempre lo que lo
que influyen en cómo se realizan también
son son las políticas que se aplican no
políticas restrictivas finalmente bueno
pues pues tienen consecuencias también
en en segundas vulneraciones o
violaciones de derechos humanos
en civil en la ciudad de mexico citó a
filippo grandi que es el alto
comisionado de naciones unidas para los
refugiados dice si la comunidad
internacional no se une para emprender
acciones que permitan atender esta
tragedia humana o bien para resolver
conflictos y encontrar soluciones
duraderas esta terrible tendencia
continuará veíamos hace algunas semanas
en la cumbre de las américas una de las
grandes conclusiones de esta cumbre fue
un documento firmado por varios países
precisamente para unirse para hacer
frente en conjunto los diferentes países
para mitigar el impacto de la migración
vemos entonces que lo que ha faltado acá
es coordinación de los países más que
buena voluntad coordinación entre los
gobiernos hacer un mecanismo común más
que políticas de país en país en este
este documento firmado la cumbre de las
américas puede ser un buen punto de
partida para una política común de la
región
ningún país puede enfrentar este
fenómeno de los movimientos mixtos y con
eso quiero decir
personas refugiadas
también migrantes económicos o personas
forzadas a ir por diferentes factores no
nadie por ningún país puede enfrentar
eso
solo no tiene que haber una política o
una coordinación y una digamos compartir
las responsabilidades de atender y
apoyar a estas poblaciones
en las diferentes etapas no sea una es
mirar los los factores raíz
que llevan a las personas a salir de sus
países
lo otro es ver de qué forma países que
pueden ser de tránsito pueden
digamos a atender de una forma
humanitaria a estas personas y luego
como los países de destino pueden acoger
e integrar a los refugiados en sus
países y ofrecerles protección
virginia su opinión sobre esto sobre la
necesidad de la unidad ya lo decía el
señor grande y sobre la necesidad y
pongo como ejemplo la cumbre de las
américas nos ha faltado a lo largo de
estos años simplemente unidad desde la
perspectiva europea ha funcionado el
bloque de unidad de la unión europea
para dar acogida a estas personas o todo
se lo está descargando a polonia rumanía
moldavia
europa no es un país no es un continente
o la unión europea no
y solidario
la gran parte de las personas refugiadas
están en países
en terceros países a europa y muy poca
gente quizá ucrania ha sido el ejemplo
donde la unión europea ha decidido
involucrarse que quizá por la cercanía
quizá por el compromiso mostrado por
ayudar a ucrania
donde donde se han desplegado recursos y
se ha permitido que de manera rápida las
personas que querían escapar de ucrania
pudieran acceder pudieran entrar en
procedimientos ágiles
dese cuenta de que por ejemplo en españa
cuando una persona llega al quiere poder
pedir protección internacional en
ocasiones tiene que esperar hasta seis o
ocho meses para hacer la solicitud y y
en cambio con ucrania se ha actuado muy
rápido en europa tenía un mecanismo para
ello que era del año 2001 y hasta ahora
no se ha puesto en marcha por lo tanto
totalmente de acuerdo en que hay una
solidaridad internacional cuando se
producen estos conflictos o no hay nada
que hacer pensemos por ejemplo la
respuesta que ha dado en europa
a afganistán
la respuesta que ha ganado europa siria
donde lo primero que se hizo fue cerrar
fronteras exigir visados cuando también
eran personas que estaban huyendo de un
conflicto que tanto virginia se ha
politizado este tema de la migración por
lo menos al nivel europeo que tanto se
ha convertido en una bandera política
para algunos partidos para algunos
políticos y ha sido manipulado
tergiversado que ha desdibujado la
imagen del refugiado y ha desdibujado
esos derechos a los que ellos pueden
acceder para poder llegar a otros
territorios
efectivamente tenemos
partidos que deshumanizan a las personas
que las convierten en objetos y es es
muy peligroso ese cierto esos discursos
como efectivamente existen en
flujos mixtos personas refugiadas y
personas migrantes económicas que
también tienen derecho a ser tratadas
con humanidad que se le tienen que
respetar los derechos pero lo que está
pasando en europa es que con la excusa
de luchar contra lo que llaman la
inmigración ilegal lo que se está
haciendo exponer cada vez más obstáculos
para que las personas que huyen de
violaciones de derechos humanos que son
refugiadas y por lo tanto que europa
debería recibir y atender porque está
obligada a ello no pueden acceder por
ejemplo en nuestras costas en nuestras
costas han muerto más de 1500 personas
durante el 2021 tratando de acceder a
europa es cada vez más complicado
mientras que por ejemplo en la frontera
en polonia en lituania se están abriendo
fronteras a personas ucranianas estamos
asistiendo a cómo están tratando a
personas de otras nacionalidades con
extrema brutalidad como recientemente
hemos denunciado en ámbito internacional
es una política hipócrita y es una
política además de lo que denominamos
doble rasero como como se ha demostrado
que han tratado bien a las personas
ucranianas que han tratado como se
merecen a las personas o craneanas lo
como están tratando de una manera muy
cruel a otras personas que también se
ven obligadas a salir por los mismos
motivos sí y esto la imagen más clara es
los pasos fronterizos entre ucrania y
polonia vemos ese flujo de personas que
ha escapado de ucrania y ha encontrado
refugio en polonia y como está
completamente frenado el paso en la
frontera entre belarús y polonia
tratando ingresar a la unión europea
pedíamos
cómo se represa van allí cientos de
ciudadanos sirios iraquíes y afganos
tratando de entrar a la unión europea
civil a regreso con usted en ciudad de
méxico para preguntarle por este tema de
la politización pero a nivel de américa
latina' aquí estos gobiernos que han
ascendido al poder muchos de un corte
populista en donde hay tantas
diferencias sociales y donde hay tantos
cambios políticos
tanto en los países una región tan
inestable en muchos términos políticos
que tanto ha sido utilizado en el tema
de los refugiados
a nivel político
en el tema de los refugiados
y de estos movimientos mixtos
tiene que ir más allá de la política no
es un tema humanitario las personas
necesitan esa atención humanitaria
y es una es una cosa que realmente debe
estar más allá de la política de los
tintes políticos que pueda haber entre
un país y otro
el
tema central
son las personas
temas entrar las personas pero entonces
quien pone en cintura a los gobiernos
para hacerlos ver este tema desde esa
óptica porque vemos el caso de países
donde las las la rigurosidad de las
medidas contra los refugiados se
incrementaban los últimos meses vemos
otros países que simplemente no hacen
nada los dejan pasar y tampoco les dan
garantías cuando están en su territorio
quién pone en cintura a los gobiernos
bueno desde el acnur hemos llamado a
diferentes gobiernos
de mantener abierto sus sistemas de
asilo que es clave o sea eso puede
significar la vida o la muerte para las
personas que están huyendo por sus vidas
por salvar sus vidas entonces el llamado
siempre ha sido eso que las personas
tengan acceso a los territorios para
poder solicitar asilo si así lo
necesitan
pero lo que lo que hemos visto en la
región realmente es son movimientos son
esfuerzos
en conjunto entre los países en
sudamérica vemos lo que es el proceso de
quito que es un proceso que une a
diferentes países para ver y trabajar el
tema de
los refugiados e inmigrantes venezolanos
en la región y en la la región de
centroamérica existe un proceso que se
conoce como el mib que también son los
gobiernos de los países que se unen los
estados se unen para compartir
experiencias y
ayudarse entre ellos a enfrentarse a
estos estos fenómenos que
realmente
tienen impactos en todos los países
sibilla virginia y les hago la misma
pregunta a las dos y es sobre esta
colaboración entre países
qué opinión hay sobre esta política de
terceros países países como por ejemplo
méxico en donde dejan a la gente
esperando una respuesta de asilo para
poder entrar a eeuu o esta controversia
que hay entre el reino unido y ruanda
por destinar allí a todas las personas
que han solicitado asilo en el reino
unido- y los envían a áfrica en donde en
muchos casos no tienen ningún tipo de
conexión con este continente ni con esta
cultura ni con este país en este tipo de
cargas que se le pone a otros países
para liberar a otros para ver cómo
agilizar sus procesos de asilo está
dando resultado el caso de méxico
funciona ruanda puede ser un buen
ejemplo para para ver en detalle cuando
entra en marcha como lo ve usted
virginia y luego lo de la palabra civil
realmente lo que está intentando hacer
en reino unido con ruanda es lo hemos
calificado como realmente tremendo
horrible inhumano
y bueno es verdad que el tribunal
europeo de derechos humanos
ha dictaminado que se tiene que parar
ese procedimiento hasta que porque no se
ha resuelto todavía las peticiones en el
reino unido pero desde luego es un paso
gravísimo y supone además que el reino
unido viola vulnera todas sus
obligaciones internacionales
no es el único país que lo hace no hay
que olvidar que también australia tiene
externalizado su sistema de asilo y aquí
en europa dinamarca también es muy
peligroso es una idea que ronda desde
hace desde hace mucho tiempo y que que
insisto va en esa misma aldea egoísta de
ciertos estados de trasladar la
responsabilidad
a terceros países a cambio de dinero y
son políticas que posiblemente
además de violar derechos humanos además
de causar muchísimo sufrimiento están
abocadas al son acaso porque en muchos
casos lo que van a provocar es que
incluso haya un aumento de mafias de
redes de tráfico y de trata de seres
humanos que es un escenario que vemos en
turquía hoy en día debemos llamarlo
türkiye también en el momento donde se
recibirán allí
muchísimos flujos de inmigrantes
procedentes de siria en el momento
álgido de la guerra civil a su opinión
sobre esto tal parece que el remedio es
peor que la enfermedad
pues
desde el acnur
hemos rechazado tanto el programa que
mencionas en méxico entre eeuu y méxico
que se llama
mpp
hemos llamado a que se levante esto que
se acabe esa política
y es como bien decía virginia la
externalización de
del asilo siempre hemos llamado a que se
tenga acceso al territorio para poder
solicitar asilo
y estos
estos diferentes programas o políticas
que se están viendo alrededor del mundo
no es algo que apoyamos desde de la
sibila pensando en proyectarse en ver
los meses que restan del 2022 y los años
venideros
dado el contexto que tenemos a nivel
mundial que proyectan ustedes en torno a
esta crisis se puede llamar crisis si
tiene uno a 100 millones de personas
tratando de huir de sus hogares porque
le pregunto por qué la pandemia kobe 19
no ha terminado muchos países están
volviendo a vivir picos de contagio
estamos debido a la situación en ucrania
al borde de una hambruna en diferentes
sectores en regiones del mundo y también
hay una crisis económica a nivel global
una alta inflación encarecimiento de
productos
dificultades para reactivar la economía
de los países que proyectan ustedes con
este escenario para los meses futuros
pues
en la proyección no es muy alentadora
[Música]
y lo más probable es que las tendencias
siguen al alza en el número de personas
desplazadas forzosamente
y por eso hacemos un llamado a toda la
comunidad internacional a los países
para que
muestren la solidaridad y la de la
respuesta
digamos que por ejemplo que se ha visto
en el caso de ucrania esa misma
respuesta se debería haber para todos
los casos de desplazamiento forzado en
el mundo e independientemente de qué
continente en qué continente está no las
personas necesitan esa respuesta
para para poder apoyarlos y virginia su
opinión que se puede hacer frente a este
caso es un hecho las cifras aumentarán
más personas tendrán que dejar sus
hogares sobre todo si finalmente
comienza esa escasez de alimentos por la
falta de trigo y de cereales procedentes
de ucrania y rusia se puede afectar a
muchos países en áfrica sobre todo
bueno ojalá yo tuviera
la solución a esto
y yo creo que lo que tenemos es también
que ampliar el conocimiento de la
población en general que las personas
sean conscientes de
que es necesario estar ahí de arrimar el
hombro' exigir a sus gobiernos que
actúen de otra manera el caso de ucrania
por ejemplo ninguna ola de solidaridad
de los ciudadanos de países europeos los
que se desplazaron a autrán ya las
fronteras a intentar ayudar de la manera
que fuese y eso tenemos que conseguir
que ocurra en todas partes sin importar
la nacionalidad sin importar el color de
piel
y revisar las políticas
al principio usted decía
precisamente no
que hay que apostar también por por
mejorar la situación en los países de
origen eso eso implica también unas
políticas de cooperación
importantes y no cerrar las fronteras y
los estados únicamente quieren plantear
sus políticas migratorias en el cierre
de fronteras están abocados al fracaso y
llevamos años en europa viéndolo y
llevamos años
contabilizando personas que mueren
intentando llegar a europa
y que además son políticas que no están
consiguiendo frenar que las personas que
intenten buscar protección internacional
lo intenten buscar las mejores
condiciones de vida también en alguno de
los informes de ley para para este para
este programa se habla de una de las
sugerencias es invertir en la paz
para hacer frente a esta situación los
gobiernos le apuestan más virginia a
levantar la economía a mover dinero en
la economía en vez de invertir en la paz
hay ejemplos de inversión en paz que
valgan la pena tener en cuenta que le
pueda servir de ejemplo a otros países
que uno pueda poner aquí sobre la mesa
porque le cuesta tanto a los gobiernos
sabiendo que les puede quitar muchos
dolores de cabeza encima se invierten en
la parte humanitaria y en la paz en sus
territorios para para poder
solucionar un poco este tema humanitario
bueno quizá al final los gobiernos se
dejan llevar por políticas muy
cortoplacistas
y del día a día y además con
mensajes fáciles de utilizar y que
muchas veces no son realistas y ese es
el gran problema
con la ex crisis económica lo primero
que se hizo fue reducir la ayuda en
cooperación internacional
por lo tanto claro hay demasiados
intereses en juego y tiene que haber una
revisión de todas las políticas y si de
otra manera es que es imposible y
tenemos que conseguir que nuestros
gobernantes a nivel global se den cuenta
y más allá de las buenas palabras
empiecen a adoptar acciones realmente
proactivas no claro
sibila quiero que demos una vuelta a la
cara de la moneda y veamos el caso que
yo citaba en la introducción del
programa y es el caso de costa de marfil
en donde se nota un incremento en el
número de personas que están regresando
una vez finaliza su periodo como
refugiados en otros estados africanos en
países cercanos o en países de europa
están regresando a costa de márfil que
deja esta buena experiencia del caso de
costa de marfil que lecciones enseña en
torno a esta llave a esa mancuerna de
trabajo entre los organismos y las
políticas del estado
pues precisamente es un caso de éxito es
un caso que nos da esperanza para otras
crisis y efectivamente lo que
mencionabas te digamos de invertir en la
paz lo que vemos acá es un conflicto que
terminó y que se crearon las condiciones
en el país para que la gente pudiera
retornar a sus casas después de 20 años
siendo refugiados y desde el acnur
invocamos una
figura legal que se llama la sensación
digamos
que básicamente
dice que las personas que que habían
salido de sus países reconocidos como
refugiados ya dejan de ser refugiados ya
no son refugiados podrían regresar y
mucha gente como dices está regresando y
realmente es un ejemplo muy alentador
en medio de digamos indicadores un poco
menos alentadores que estamos viendo
virginia también su opinión sobre este
caso de costa de marfil y cito también
en esas cifras pequeñas pero también
representativas de muchas personas que
están regresando a ucrania
a pesar de que la situación allí sigue
siendo muy tensa con la invasión de las
tropas rusas incluso en venezuela en
donde la situación económica tampoco es
fácil muchas personas están regresando a
estos países
es un poco lo que decimos las personas
abandonar tu país abandonar tu entorno
no no es una decisión fácil y cuando se
vuelven a dar las condiciones adecuadas
la gente quiere regresar o la gente
y tiene un proyecto de vida que quiere
continuar y
y se tienen que dar las condiciones
cuando cuando se dan las condiciones la
gente regresa porque porque de un futuro
para para poder continuar mientras tanto
no no va a ser así por lo tanto es lo
que hay que hacer es crear esas
condiciones en eso en todos los países
pero también asumir que hay en otros
lugares donde esas condiciones no va a
ser fácil
y reconstruir a un corto plazo y por lo
tanto tiene que haber otro tipo de
respuesta pero la gente la gente retorna
cuando cuando tienen las condiciones
adecuadas claro que retorna retornan
personas refugiadas y retornan también
personas que emigraron económicamente y
que luego han vuelto a su país para
continuar con su proyecto de vida
si vila en este caso como en el de costa
de marfil veinte años después muchos
retornan el caso de colombia cincuenta
años de guerra son cinco décadas en los
que millones de colombianos han salido
del país en cuba' igual han escapado del
régimen político que hay allí desde hace
ya muchas décadas esto como parte de la
historia de una sociedad una sociedad
como la colombiana como la cubana como
la venezolana no va a ser la misma
después de estas olas migratorias 6
millones de venezolanos fuera del país
pocos empiezan a regresar como cambiar
una sociedad después de haber sido
refugiados de haber sido desplazados
cambia mucho se cambia tanto los países
desde donde salen las personas como los
países que los acogen porque el
intercambio cultural el intercambio
[Música]
digamos de diferentes nacionalidades con
diferentes
experiencias enriquecen a los países no
estoy hablando de los países de acogida
para los países desde donde salen las
personas digamos son países que están o
han sufrido algún tipo de conflicto
algún tipo de
situaciones críticas que han llevado a
las personas a salir entonces más que la
salida de las personas creo que lo que
marca la historia del país son esas
situaciones que llevan a las personas a
salir
virginia su opinión cómo cambia una
sociedad después de que por ejemplo
venezuela 6 millones de ciudadanos
abandonan el país los que quedan los que
regresan como vuelve a ser una sociedad
que puede ensamblarse y a volver a tener
un sentido de identidad
unificado
bueno en españa es el entorno que yo más
conozco sufrió una migración importante
muchísimas personas de españa tuvieron
que salir principalmente por una
dictadura
persiguió a muchas personas por sus
ideas y también por una crisis económica
yo creo que las migraciones siempre han
enriquecido a todas las sociedades y
enriquecen tanto a la sociedad acogida
como también a la sociedad donde la
donde se retornan
las migraciones siempre han sido
positivas y siempre y siempre han sido
también un punto de progreso en todas
las sociedades y muchos países se han
construido a raíz de estas olas
migratorias creo que el caso más grande
que podemos tener por lo menos en el
continente americano es eeuu que tiene
una sociedad completamente diversa
compuesta por diferentes etnias y
personas procedentes de diferentes
países me quedan pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa hagamos las
conclusiones entonces virginia y civil
así les parece siempre lo digo no
tenemos la bola de cristal para saber
cuál es el futuro de las situaciones o
de los temas que estamos analizando aquí
en el programa pero que ven ustedes a
futuro en una agudización de la de la
situación ya vemos que la coyuntura no
es la mejor pero ven ustedes de pronto
algunos visos de unidad entre los países
para empezar a poner en marcha políticas
que de pronto en un futuro de corto
plazo pueden empezar a dar resultados
comienzo entonces con civil and ciudad
de mexico para la conclusión
pues
pareciera que ensayábamos fue fue un
poco la conclusión que salió de como
mencionaste la cumbre de las américas
hay un consenso que va creciendo sobre
la necesidad de trabajar en conjunto de
buscar soluciones
en conjunto y de compartir
responsabilidades pero no trasladarlas
no que sea realmente enfoques regionales
enfoques en conjunto que
busquen
enfrentar a estos estos fenómenos
virginia su conclusión
bueno
mi conclusión es que no es fácil pero
que hay que hay que pelear por ello y
que en el fondo los gobernantes saben
que buscan soluciones conjuntas o
van a fracasar por lo tanto tenemos que
seguir empujando la sociedad en general
la sociedad civil organizada para que
para que haya un cambio de rumbo y
realmente se trabaje conjuntamente y se
trabaje sobre todo a favor de las
personas pues a sibila ya virginia les
agradezco por haber hecho este análisis
para la audiencia de france 24 un tema
que claramente toca profundamente a la
sociedad latinoamericana de diferentes
países de nuestra región muchas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros ustedes
pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y preguntas a través de las
redes sociales se pueden seguir en
sintonía de france 24
[Música]